turning now to the conflict in Sudan
there are reports that airstrikes have
killed at least seven civilians in the
capital Khartoum there are also
suggestions that the aid group Doctors
Without Borders could pull out of the
country after one of its Aid convoys was
attacked well let's go straight to our
correspondent hibber Morgan who is on
the ground there in Khartoum here but
are we seeing another intensification
here in the fighting
well because of the lack of a ceasefire
agreed upon by both sides the
paramilitary rapid support forces and
the Sudanese army fighting very much
continues here in the capital Khartoum
now the resistance Committees of the
Southern belt the southern part of the
capital reported that several civilians
were killed as a result of airstrikes
launched by the Sudanese Army against
positions of the paramilitary rapid
support forces in the southern part of
the capital several people were also
injured along with properties destroyed
and they say that those who they were
able to save and who survived the
airstrikes were taken to hospitals for
treatment but fighting discontinue just
a short while ago we were able to hear
gunfire in parts of onderman we can
regularly hear the artillery and as I'm
talking to you Anastasia we can hear the
Antonov plane belonging to the Sudanese
Army flying overhead so that shows that
four months into the conflict the
fighting does continue with no signs of
it abating as you say hibber we're
several months into this conflict now we
know that hospital and Aid groups have
been truly struggling how are they now
holding up especially given what we're
hearing from msf
well we've spoken to doctors repeatedly
since this conflict started and they
always say the same thing that they are
in a dire catastrophic situation many
hospitals like basic necessities to be
able to operate we're talking about
anesthesia bandages to be able to to uh
to wrap up injuries as a result of the
fighting the medic group Doctors Without
Borders said that their team uh in uh in
in the southern parts of the capital was
assaulted 18 people being physically
assaulted by who they identified as
armed men without clarifying whether
it's the Sudanese army or the
paramilitary rapid support forces and
they also hinted that should those
attacks continue then they will not be
able to continue their operations and
obviously with Medics saying that the
situation is catastrophic and that they
regularly are in need of assistance as
an organization like Doctors Without
Borders pulling out would affect the
health situation here in the country and
especially in the capital Khartoum of
course hibber Morgan there with all the
letters for us on the ground in Khartoum
thank you thank you